los analistas que siguen la guerra ven
estos últimos movimientos de los Últimos
Días como la preparación tanto del
ejército de Moscú como el ucraniano para
esa contraofensiva que se espera con la
llegada del buen tiempo hoy por ejemplo
aquí en la región de saporilla donde es
una de las regiones donde se espera que
suceda esa contraofensiva hizo un día
soleado pero lo que nos cuentan los
soldados en el frente es que sigue
habiendo bastante pantano en algunas
regiones y especialmente están a la
espera de mayor armamento para poder
realizar esta contraofensiva que
realmente nadie sabe cuándo vaya a
suceder lo que sí se ha visto por
ejemplo en el día de ayer fue el anuncio
de cómo las tropas ucranianas cruzaban
al este del Río nipper en la región de
gersón una región que está a ese lado
del río controlada por las fuerzas rusas
no solamente tenían presencia de tropas
sino que se sabía que habían hecho
misiones de reconocimiento hasta ahora
no se sabe cuán tan grande es la
presencia ucraniana pero lo que se han
dicho las autoridades de la región es
que las fuerzas de Moscú están empezando
a evacuar personas de poblaciones en las
cercanías de esta parte del río y
también se ha conocido que las tropas
ucranianas tendrían el control de dos
Islas importantes en el río que han
estado en contienda desde que las tropas
de Moscú se retiraron de gersón a
finales de noviembre la única capital de
provincia recordemos que estuvo en poder
de las fuerzas rusas algo parecido hemos
visto aquí en la región de saporilla
aquí nos cuenta la población de ciudades
que están en la línea de batalla que
ambas fuerzas están
estudiándose la una a la otra
especialmente dicen que los rusos
utilizan desde las últimas semanas mayor
ataques con aviones lo hacen desde su
territorio y estarían tratando de probar
qué tan fuertes en la defensa antiaérea
de los ucranianos que siguen insistiendo
en que necesitan mayor ayuda en este
campo